l'information circule sur la toile
depuis déjà plusieurs semaines un
concert serait-on préparation du rock
anticommuniste défendu par des
groupuscules néonazis le 18 avril à
Tours ou dans sa région quatre groupes
seraient invités français et britannique
des références nous les milieux
d'extrême droite et un discours commun
basé sur la haine raciale
devant avoir des finalités de
sensibilisation voire d'enroulement de
sympathisants ou de faire connaître par
la musique des idées qui si elles
étaient exprimées directement on va dire
sur un registre directement politique
risquerait de susciter des réticences
donc il y a la volonté d'utiliser la
musique pour s'adresser un public jeune
qui s'intéresse au rock et qui est
curieux de connaître de nouveaux groupes
et de cette manière-là de faire passer
des idées politiques avec l'annonce de
la venue de ce groupe largement diffusé
dans les milieux consacré depuis les
années 80 les collectifs antifascistes
craignent que 100 à 300 personnes ne se
déplacent à ce rendez-vous des
regroupements qui ne sont pas illégaux
dans une certaine mesure ce qui relève
des discours qui sont tenus que ça soit
les textes de chansons ou des
interventions des des musiciens ce
qu'ils disent entre deux chansons bon
des propos publics parce que voilà enfin
un caractère de publicité ouvertement
racistes antisémites des appels à la
violence un peu tombé sous le sous le
coup de la loi évidemment reste à savoir
si ce concert aura effectivement lieu et
à quel endroit là encore les
protagonistes de ce type de
rassemblement se montre très discret les
autorités quant à elles suivent ce
dossier depuis plus d'un mois